The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Today we start a new
section of NP-hardness.
I think it'll be one
lecture about Hamiltonicity.
So Hamiltonian cycle and path.
We've talked about this briefly.
But cycle is just a cycle
visiting every vertex exactly
once.
And usually when you talk about
a graph being Hamiltonian,
you mean that there's a
Hamiltonian cycle, also called
a Hamiltonian tour, or
Hamiltonian circuit all
mean the same thing.
And then there's
Hamiltonian path.
Another problem we
have looked at before.
And same thing, but path that
visits every vertex exactly
once.
These are pretty much
the same problem,
but different versions are
useful in different settings.
In case you're curious
where this comes from,
it comes from this game
introduced by Hamilton in 1857.
He was the royal astronomer
of Ireland back then,
but he had fun
with games as well.
So here you have something like
the graph of a dodecahedron.
The dual is an icosahedron,
hence the name,
and you want to find a
Hamiltonian circuit through it.
Or there's actually a two-player
game where one person chooses
a subset of the
graph, the other one
tries to find Hamiltonian
circuit in that subset.
So that's where
Hamiltonicity comes from.
But for us today it is a
nice NP-complete problem.
We've actually seen one proof
that planar max degree four,
I think, Hamiltonicity is hard.
That was in the
planar SAT discussion,
and this is the original
paper that does planar 3SAT.
And there was this proof--
I guess it's not actually
max degree four, probably a
max degree six or something.
We argued the directed
case-- this apparently
works for the undirected
case-- we'll get
an even stronger result here.
In general, the problem
is NP-complete in a lot
of different special cases,
such as the one we saw.
For example, if you're
looking for a path
and you're given the
two end points-- so
normally you'd say is
there a Hamiltonian path
or is there Hamiltonian cycle?
Those are both hard
in general graphs.
But if I give you a graph and
I give you two nodes, s and t,
and I want to know is
there-- so here's the graph,
here's s and t-- I want to
know is there a path that
starts at s, ends at t.
This is NP-hard.
By reduction from Hamiltonian
cycle, tell me what to do.
AUDIENCE: You add a new node
which has connection to s
and t and nothing else.
ERIK DEMAINE: Add a
new node connected
to s and t and nothing else.
Yeah.
So we'll add this new node
x, connected to s and t.
What's interesting
about adding a degree
two node is you know it
has to be in the cycle,
so you know that these two
edges have to be in the cycle.
AUDIENCE: Also, if
it's directed you
can direct those two so that--
ERIK DEMAINE: It's not directed.
All these are going
to be undirected.
This would preserve
directedness if you wanted it.
So there you go.
So if Hamiltonian cycle's
hard, then Hamiltonian path
given two end points is hard.
Easy warm-up.
It's also NP-complete
for planar three regular,
three connected graphs,
where every face
has degree at least five.
But probably already met them.
It's NP-hard for
bipartite graphs.
These are all various
results proved in the '70s.
It's going to be hard
for squares of graphs.
Squares of graphs
is interesting.
This is whenever you
have a length two path,
you add an edge.
It's a square, and
that's still hard.
Another fun problem is
computing a Hamiltonian cycle
given a Hamiltonian
path is also hard.
On the other hand, some
variations are easy.
So you have to be a
little bit careful.
There are a lot of papers
about various graphs
that are always
Hamiltonian and usually
when they're always Hamiltonian
there's a good algorithm
to find them.
Here are just a
couple of examples.
One is cubes of graphs.
So if you take all
length three paths
and connect them by an edge,
or maybe length less than
or equal to three-- I'm not
sure exactly-- that's easy.
All such graphs are Hamiltonian,
where with squares it's
still hard.
So that's kind of a limit.
And the other one
here is planar-- three
connector graphs is NP-complete.
Planar four connector
graphs is polynomial.
This is a tough theorem,
one of many tough theorems.
All such graphs are Hamiltonian.
So those are a few
cases to worry about.
We will see some more today.
And these are relatively simple.
We're going to
prove even stricter
versions of this
problem NP-complete,
but it starts to give you
the flavor of what's there.
In fact the first
one we will prove
is-- this may seem a little
weird because I wanted
to do undirected,
but we're going
to make it undirected
in a moment.
We're going to do a
series of reductions.
First one we'll do is planar
max degree three graphs.
So this will be a
reduction from 3SAT.
So the general idea,
and please wait why you
should care about this problem.
We're going to reduce it
to another more interesting
version of Hamiltonicity.
But here's one way to represent
3SAT as Hamiltonicity--
another way, similar to
the one we did before.
We got clauses here
over on the left.
Here some of the
clauses have size two,
but it works for the three case.
Here we have the variables.
And the key concept
here is this notation.
This is shorthand for a
more complicated gadget,
which is to say that these
two things should not
be both chosen.
This is an exclusive OR.
Exactly one of them
should be chosen.
So that forces x1 to be
the opposite of x1 bar,
and it also lets you
duplicate things.
So here we get multiple
copies of the variable.
You keep doing that
several times you
get many copies of variable
and its complement.
And then we're also going to
use some connections like this.
We're going to need
a crossover gadget,
but this will say
that you-- well,
so this is going to
be some clause which
it's not literally as drawn.
Again, this is notation
for a gadget the
is going to force at least one
of these to be traversable.
And so that overall
should represent 3SAT.
We need a clause gadget.
We need this exclusive
OR so that we can split,
duplicate things.
Overall, the cycle's
going to do this.
It's going to visit all the
variables in order, then
all the clauses in order.
So we can't get anything
interesting out of planarity,
because that graph
with these connections
is not going to be planar.
So we'll need a crossover.
And those are the
three gadgets we need.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Why were
you using exclusively
working with [INAUDIBLE]
variables [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIK DEMAINE: So the idea
is here there's a choice.
Do I choose this edge or this
edge in the Hamiltonian cycle.
And I want the choice
for this copy of x1
to be the same as
for that copy of x1.
So the exclusive OR forces each
instance of x1 to be the same.
In general, if
there's k instances,
you'd have k of these.
AUDIENCE: Can you connect that?
Use the same guy to
connect it to the instance
inside the clause?
ERIK DEMAINE: I guess the reason
why we need two copies here is
that you can't-- well, see you
can't have 2 XOR gadgets going
to the same place.
So it will be clear once
we've seen the XOR gadget.
We want two distinct copies so
that these two things can point
to different copies of x1.
That's why we're making
a copy like that.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: OK.
Excellent.
Actually, same slide.
I should just show them.
So here is-- maybe let's
start with the XOR gadget
because the clause-- ah,
clause doesn't actually use it.
So the XOR gadget is if we have
two edges of opposite direction
relative to the way
we're being connected.
I think it also works
in the other way
because these are-- no,
these are also opposite
if you redraw it this way.
We're just going to
have this picture, which
can be traversed.
Either this guy
can come in-- here
we're really using direction,
directionality of the graph.
You can traverse
the top edge or you
can traverse the bottom edge
in the opposite direction.
But you can't just turn around
because then these vertices
would be uncovered.
And as soon as
you've gone this far,
you can't come back this way.
So once you enter here
you're forced to leave there.
Once you enter
here you're forced
to leave there, if you
want to cover everything.
So that's an exclusive
OR, and at least
one of those better happen.
So that's what
happens over there.
And also what we'll
end up doing here,
except we also need
the crossing case.
On the other hand,
for the clause,
the idea is basically there's a
cycle over here, which is fine.
But somehow that
cycle for that clause
has to be connected into the big
cycle that we've drawn already.
And at least one
of the variables
needs to connect to that.
So the idea is we
can come up here--
so also these vertices
need to be covered.
So we can come up here,
go over here, loop around,
and be happy.
And then we've grab
the entire cycle.
Also, when we've
grabbed this cycle,
we can also grab these vertices.
All of them.
That's only going to be
possible if this is possible.
So in the outer side, we can't
go here and then up here.
We can go here over here.
That's also fine.
OK.
Good.
I see.
So that the issue is-- so
these are actually flexible.
These guys can be covered
basically from the right side
or from the left
side, either way.
So it doesn't matter whether
you take this path or this path.
But at least one of these
sort of pairs of edges,
as they're drawn
over here, you need
to be able to choose
the left choice
and, therefore,
get the big cycle.
And the issue with that is
because you have this XOR,
it's an exclusive OR, exactly
one of those two things
must be true.
So in some cases,
you'll be forced
to choose the right thing.
If this variable
chose the right path,
then this one will also have to
choose the right path because
of this exclusive OR,
and preventing you
from grabbing the cycle.
You're fine in this clause
if at least one of them
you choose the left path.
In fact, if you
look very closely
there's some bold
edges indicating
which one's got chosen here.
So here, two of them were
on the right, one of them
was on the left for this clause.
In general, if at least
one of them is on the left
you're OK for the clause.
Clear.
The high level now.
This would work fine if we
didn't care about planarity,
but I want planar
directed max degree three.
At this point we should be
So that's an improvement from
last time in terms of degrees.
And then there's this fun
figure for the crossover.
So in general, that's
just a repetition
of what our XOR gadget was.
Now we have crossing
XOR constraints.
So here's a typical example.
Let's say we have
this XOR trying
to go from there to there and
it crosses these other XORs.
So what we're going to
do is build something
like that gadget for the
vertical connection with this,
and this, and this, and this.
And we duplicate these edges.
That doesn't help you-- I mean
it's the same as that picture,
I just happened
to duplicate them.
The reason we do
that is we're going
to put XORs across like this,
and this forces an alternation.
So if this is in,
then this must be out,
so this must be in,
so this must be out,
so this must be in, and
so on all the way through.
And so that forces an
XOR between this edge
and that edge.
Cool?
So that is the crossing
x over XOR gadget, which
you plug into all
of these pictures,
and you end up with planar
directed max degree three.
All right?
So far so good.
Next-- I have a goal.
I'm still not going
to tell you the goal.
Next one is going to be planar
bipartite max degree three.
Undirected.
This is going to be one of
our simplest reductions ever.
There it is.
So the cool thing
about max degree three
directed-- I mean there are
few cases you can exclude.
You can't have three
incoming edges.
outgoing edges.
It would be pretty hard
to have a cycle that
includes such vertices.
So you could have
degree two vertices,
but I don't think
we even had any.
Did I say that we had
degree two in this picture?
Probably not.
I mean if we did we could
double the edge or something.
So that was probably actually
planar directed three regular.
OK, but now undirected.
But you can basically
have two edges in,
one out, or one
edge in and two out.
And we're going to convert that.
So the interesting
thing here, you
have to visit this
vertex, which means
you have to visit this edge
in any Hamiltonian cycle.
Because once you
come here you've
got to leave on that edge.
Similarly, you have
to visit this edge.
You can tell that just
from this picture.
So we call these forced edges.
And we can represent that
by adding a vertex there.
It says, hey, you've
got to visit that edge.
So you're going to visit it
by that little path there.
And now things are bipartite.
And the bipartiteness
is essentially
forcing the
directionality as well.
So let's say when you come
into a vertex and you're blue,
so that means
these guys have had
to have been red,
whenever you leave,
you first visit a red
vertex and then go.
So here you're coming in
again as blue, and then
before you leave you turn red.
And so because you've satisfied
directionality over here,
the outgoing edge here
becomes an incoming edge
to the next vertex,
that means you'll
be going into a blue
vertex either because it's
like this or like that.
And you are effectively
forcing directionality.
I mean everything
could be reversed.
Because you're always
coming into a blue vertex
and leaving on a red.
That forces you to be going
from the tail of an arrow
to the head of an arrow.
So same thing by symmetry.
So these problems are actually
really close to each other.
These were done in
different papers,
but this was an older one.
And then this problem was
introduced for another reason,
which is grid graphs.
This is where I
really want to go.
So the idea with the
grid graph is you,
let's say, have a set of
points on the square lattice.
And then you're going to have
an edge whenever you have
two points at unit distance.
So let me draw an example.
Cheat, and have some
examples drawn for me.
This was in a much more recent
paper, but some nice pictures.
So we're just choosing a set
of points in the square grid.
And then whenever we
have two points that
are a unit distance
apart, you're
forced to have an edge there.
You can't say there's no edge.
That would be a sub-graph
of a grid graph.
But for example, when
this point is absent,
you don't get any
connections through here.
So these are all
examples of grid graphs.
Now there's one special
case, or in general, we
distinguish-- there's sort
of three types of faces
in such a planar graph.
There's what you might
call pixels-- little one
by one squares.
There's the outside
face, and then there's
everything else
which we call holes.
So any non-length for
face we call hole.
If there are no holes we
call it a solid grid graph.
This is interesting
because solid grid
graphs you can
solve Hamiltonicity
in polynomial time.
It's not always possible, but
there is a polynomial time
algorithm for solving
the solid grid graph
case by Umens and Lenhart, '97.
A very complicated algorithm.
Luckily, this is a
hardness proof class
so I don't have to cover it.
I'm going to focus on the
hardness when you allow holes.
So this is where things get fun.
We are going to reduce-- we did
a reduction from here to here.
We're going to do a
reduction from here to here.
So we're going to suppose that
we want to solve Hamiltonicity
in planar bipartite max
degree three graphs,
and we're going to convert such
a planar bipartite max degree
three.
Graph into a grid graph
that acts the same.
So the first step is to
draw the graph on a grid.
That's pretty obvious.
So here's an example
of what we want to do,
and then this is a
picture of how to do it.
Suppose you have a
bipartite planar graph.
Not obvious this is
planar, but it's obvious
that it's bipartite.
It happens to be planar.
It's max degree three.
And the vertices are
labeled, the XIs and the YIs,
and you can see the
corresponding labeling here.
So not all of the grid dots
are going to be labeled.
Some of them are just auxiliary.
In order to connect
to vertices we're
going to have to draw paths,
orthogonal paths on the grid.
But the key thing I
want is the square grid
has a two-coloring inherently,
and I want that two-coloring
to match this two-coloring.
That's what I would call a
parity-preserving embedding
of the Graph
And you can see in this example,
the three XIs are white,
and the three YIs are black.
And if you check all the
edges they should correspond.
Just ignore the
dash lines-- that's
to show you the grid underlying.
So this is a valid embedding.
How do we do it?
Well, we just take any
embedding in the grid.
It's well known that if you
have a max degree four graph
you can draw it in the
grid without crossings,
and each edge is some
orthogonal polyline.
I won't prove that here.
And then suppose the parity's
wrong for some vertex.
Suppose you draw vertex B
and it happens to be black,
but you want it to be white?
Then I'm just going to
shift it over by one
and do these kinds of
wiggles, and that's it.
So you scale everything
by a factor of three
and you'll have room
to do those wiggles.
So take an arbitrary
orthogonal grid drawing
and then add the
wiggles whenever
things are in the wrong
parity and now every vertex
will be in the correct parity.
That will be crucial
for the reduction.
So at this point we've got an
orthogonal parity-preserving
drawing of our given bipartite
planar max degree three graph.
And the issue is there are sort
of two types of vertices here.
There's the ones there
we really need to visit,
and then there's
these other vertices
which are representing edges.
We don't need to visit every
edge-- that's the tour problem.
Hamiltonian tour, we just need
to visit every vertex which
are the labeled dots over here.
So this is where things get fun.
Here is a key gadget before we
see the overall architecture.
These are called tentacles
in the original paper.
I'm calling them edge
gadgets because they're just
simulating a single edge
of the original graph,
but tentacles is cooler.
Whichever you prefer.
So these are the
dots that haven't all
been drawn explicitly here.
And so it's just like a two
by and sort of corridor.
The base version would be this,
but if you want to have turns,
which we're going to
need 90 degree turns,
it looks more like this.
And there's basically
two ways to cover this.
Sort of three ways.
But the way parity
will work out,
there will only be two
ways that we care about.
There's not a variable gadget.
It looks like maybe
a variable gadget,
but that's not how
we're using it.
So one way you can visit this
gadget is to zigzag like this.
We've seen this in pretty
much all of our planar
Hamiltonicity proofs.
The core idea's the same.
You could start at A and end
at C, or you could start at B
and end at D, and that's
true in this version as well.
Once you start
alternating you're
forced to alternate
all the way through.
So you could imagine
using that for a wire,
but we're not going to
use the two alternations.
By parity we'll be forced to
do it one way or the other.
We'll be told whether
we're starting or ending
in one of them, I think.
Well, it won't matter.
But there's this other
way you could visit,
which is to just go all
the way down then come
all the way back.
This is going to
correspond to an edge that
is in the Hamiltonian cycle.
Because I want to start
at some vertex up here,
and I want to end at some vertex
down here if I follow the edge.
This is going to correspond
to an edge that we don't use.
Because at this
vertex, I still need
to cover these vertices
somehow, but I don't
want that to really matter.
I want this edge to
be coverable for free.
So the idea is as I visit
this vertex we're just going
to zip down here, zip back up.
And all these vertices
get visited for free.
It's not really
part of the tour.
Let me show you in
some more detail.
Here's what a vertex looks like.
Vertex is just going to
be a 3 by 3 grid of dots.
Now, remember there are
two kinds of vertices.
There's the ones
that were-- so again,
we're expanding everything
for this to work out.
The vertices that
were originally white
and the vertices that
were originally black.
It doesn't matter
which is which,
but there's two
classes of vertices.
And we're going to attach
the edge gadgets, which were
these 2 by n kind of things.
So this is all edge gadget here.
We're going to attach
it to a vertex that's
white in this sort of flush
length two connection.
So this is the variable up
here, this 3 by 3 thing,
and here we're having two edges
connecting to the edge gadget.
For the black
vertices we're only
going to have a single
edge connecting them.
This is called a pin
connection, between the wire
gadget or the tentacle,
and the 3 by 3 down here.
OK.
Why?
Because.
So here let's
consider two vertices
that are attached by an edge.
So they have opposite parity.
One's-- I've forgotten
which is which.
This is white and
this black I think.
Here we have the pin connection.
Here we have the
length two connection.
And the idea is there's exactly
two ways to traverse this edge,
as we saw.
But now you can see
the connections.
Let me put it that way.
So the idea is, well,
maybe you choose
to use that edge in the
cycle, and so I want
to be able to just traverse it.
Everything is good.
And so here I know
that I'm entering
at this point, which
means I know that I'll
have to be exiting here.
So the parities are forced.
So the zigzag parity is forced.
The other possibility, because
there's only one connection
here, you couldn't traverse
this way and then come back.
But from this side you could
traverse and then come back.
And it doesn't touch
the vertex at all.
So the idea is you could
ignore this edge entirely
and it gets covered for free,
provided once you erase this,
this edge is in the
Hamiltonian tour.
And at this point I should
mention what all this labeling
means on the vertex gadget.
The idea is for
this vertex, if you
start at any of the PIs,
any of the four corners--
any of the private
investigators-- then
you can end at any other
PI, PJ in such a way
that you visit all
three of the EIs.
AUDIENCE: There
are four of them.
ERIK DEMAINE: There
EI, EO, EIEI-O. No, OK.
So let me get to the point.
You could start
at PI, end at PJ,
and visit all the vertices and
all of the EIs, all of the EKs.
So for example, if I want
to go from here to here,
I can go like this,
visited all the edges.
If I want to go
from here to here,
I can go like this,
visited all the vertices,
visited all the EIs.
So that's good because
each of these EIs
is potentially attached
to an edge gadget
and we might want to visit
all of the things out there
and come back.
OK?
So you see the reason why we
only want a pin connection here
is if we had a full
connection with two edges,
you might imagine that
you come out here,
do something, eventually
do other stuff,
and then come back on this path.
But because we have a
pin connection always
on one of the two
sides, you can't have
two separate traversal paths.
As soon as you get here you
have to turn back around.
If you went this
way, then this guy
would never be
visible in a cycle.
So that's the key thing.
This was one of the
EIs, and so the idea
is you can completely
forget about this path.
You can just think
about going from one
of these white
vertices to another.
In general, it's
going to correspond
to which edge gadgets that
vertex gadget is connected to.
So you can go from
one vertex to another.
You will visit this edge.
And so you can add in this
part if you don't use the edge.
If you do use the
edge, then you'll
be starting from one
of these white vertices
and you want to go to this one.
And then you'll
follow this path.
And then you get to
this vertex, then
you'll go from one
of black vertices
to one of the other
four corners, and so on.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Should that
line of three white dots,
shouldn't they all be black?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yes,
this should be black.
It's not my fault.
It could be the
scanner or it could
be-- this is a hand-drawn
figure as you might guess.
So yeah, that should be black.
Everything should alternate.
So you can tell the
parity's a vertex based
on the color of the corners.
Any other questions
about that proof?
OK.
So this is pretty cool.
And I would say
Hamiltonicity in grid graphs
is used a lot as a base
problem for reductions
in computational geometry,
especially tour-like problems.
And you'll notice a theme.
Every reduction so far, except
the very first one I guess,
was from one type of
Hamiltonian circuit
to another type of
Hamiltonian circuit.
And this tends to be common that
you can work within Hamiltonian
circuit and modify your
graph in all sorts of ways
to get to a very simplified
version of Hamiltonian circuit.
And that's cool.
And so you get a lot of mileage
just within the Hamiltonian
circuit family.
Cool.
Let me give you a couple of
applications right off the bat.
What?
AUDIENCE: This is going
back a little bit,
but are there any sort of
natural families of graphs
for which finding
a Hamiltonian path
is strictly easier
than finding a circle?
ERIK DEMAINE: I think the only--
this problem would be easy.
Find a Hamiltonian path
given a Hamiltonian path.
But I'm not aware of any other
problems where a Hamiltonian
path is easier than cycle.
I mean in general,
you can reduce one
to the other somehow.
That's maybe a little tricky
without the two given end
points.
And if you have
lots of structure,
like planarity and through
regularity it's not so clear,
but definitely Hamiltonian path
is still hard in this problem.
I think one easy
way to do that is
to just do the same
chain of reductions,
but start with Hamiltonian
path instead of cycle
and follow through, and
pretty much every step
should still be path-based.
So it's actually useful.
We'll want Hamiltonian path and
grid graphs also at some point.
But what I showed was
Hamiltonian cycle.
So for pretty much everywhere
they seem to be the same,
but it would be cool to
find an example where
they have different complexity.
OK.
So here's another problem.
Euclidean TSP.
Traveling salesman problem.
You're given a set of
points in the plane.
Better not make it too big
because this might be hard.
And I want to find a tour.
It visits every
point exactly once,
and has minimum total
length, Euclidean length.
So the usual notion of length.
I claim this is NP-hard.
Now, this is a little scary.
Most of the problems we've been
working with are very discrete.
I mean the output here
is sort of discrete.
You choose a permutation
on the points.
But it feels like there's
almost no control here.
I mean how would I construct
localized gadgets when
I can just jump from any point
to any other point at any time
as long as that point
hasn't already been used.
But it's really easy to
prove this is NP-hard
given what we just did.
Oh, I should say, here's
a full worked out example,
so this is what I
should be pointing at.
This was the parity-preserving
graph that we drew before.
And this is what you
get in the reduction,
along with actual
solution, which is
the one drawn in orange here.
So you can see read that
off, because wherever
you see zigzags, that's where
you're using the path here.
So these correspond, and
then this corresponds.
And then up and over.
And then the unused edges,
the not orange ones,
that's where we get
these kinds of loops,
starting from the
vertices of one parity,
I guess the white ones, and
then going to the black ones
and turning around
at the pin joint.
Cool.
So given this is hard,
why is this hard?
So the decision
problem, let's say,
is I give you a set of points.
I give you the desired
length of the tour.
I want to know is there a tour,
visits every point exactly
once, and has length at
most that given length.
AUDIENCE: So if you
look at a grid graph,
you'll have some
number of nodes,
which means the tour would
have to necessarily have-- it
can just choose those points.
The tour would necessarily
have at least-- exactly
that many edges,
and each edge would
have to have length
at least one,
because the close [INAUDIBLE]
points is one apart.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yup.
AUDIENCE: And so if you
just counter [INAUDIBLE]
those points and say
that that's the desired
length of your tour,
then you can only
do that if you can get through
this by following only edges
that are length one.
ERIK DEMAINE: Exactly.
So we're going to reduce
from this problem.
Given such a grid
graph, the reduction
just looks at the vertices,
throws away the edges.
That is our input-- those
points are the input to TSP.
And then the claim
is that every tour--
let's say there are end
points in this picture.
Every tour has to have length
at least n, as you say,
because they're end points,
the total number of edges
is n in a cycle, a
Hamiltonian cycle,
and every edge must have
length at least one,
because that's the nearest pair.
And so that's a lower bound.
And then on the
other hand, if there
is a tour that
has length only n,
then it must actually
be a Hamiltonian cycle
in this graph,
because then you're
only using edges that
exist in the grid graph.
So it's really the same problem.
Euclidean TSP really is
a special case of this.
Cool.
This problem was proved
hard much earlier.
Hamiltonicity and grid graph.
But here is now a nice simple
proof using what we know.
I'll tell you more
reasons in a little bit,
but I have one more at this
point, which is platform games.
I don't have a graphic
because there's
so many games that
could apply here,
Super Mario Brothers among them.
Suppose you have a little
dude, you can walk around.
And you've got some
kind of coins--
I don't know how to draw coins.
They almost look like eyeballs.
But anyway, you've
got a bunch of coins
which you want to collect.
And you have some way
that you can walk around.
If you're a top-down
game, then that's
pretty much the
entire reduction.
And then also you have a timer.
So timer plus collectibles--
ables or ibles?
Ables.
And any such game is
NP-hard, at least,
because if you want to get
all of these coins, that's
like vertices you need to visit.
As I say, a top-down game
you're walking in a grid graph.
The time limit will
prevent us from going out
into the white space because
there's no coins there.
And so if the timeline limit
is exactly the number of coins,
and every step you make
you have to get a coin,
then that will force you to only
follow-- the edges in the grid
graph can't go out here.
No obstacles needed.
And you understand that in
the real game, of course,
there might be stuff
happening here.
Maybe there's a ladder
so you can go up here.
You just have to set up
all these traversal lengths
to take the same amount of
time in under optimal play.
And then you can simulate a
ton of video games in this way.
This is a result.
This is in Fun 2010 by Forishek.
So some reasons why you care.
A lot of games map
naturally onto grids.
A lot of real problems
can map onto grids.
In general, grids
will be very helpful.
So next problem I
want to solve is--
by solve, I mean
show hard, as usual.
Let's say, max degree
three grid graphs.
I don't have a great
motivation-- well,
I have a motivation for this.
Probably others that
I'm not aware of.
I didn't actually know about
this result until recently.
It's pretty cool.
If you look at this reduction,
there are some vertices
that-- I mean here
we're drawing the cycle,
but some vertices
have degree four.
Of course, every grid
graph is max degree four.
And max degree two is pretty
easy to solve Hamiltonicity.
So what's left is
max degree three.
So a natural question in
between is can you do max degree
three grid graphs.
The claim is that is also hard.
And it's going to be
basically the same proof,
but we're going to change all
the gadgets, most of them.
There's one shared author.
This was Eti Papadimitriou
and Szwarcfiter.
And then this is
Papadimitriou and Vazirani
a couple years later.
So this is actually
very similar to the edge
gadget we saw before.
Here's the old edge gadget.
Before when we had a turn
we had a degree four vertex.
I want to get rid of that,
and I'm going to get rid of it
by just sort of shifting these
things apart and blowing up
this circle, this cycle.
So I end up with a
bigger cycle here,
end up with an edge
connection there.
But effectively, it's the
same kind of topology.
If you're coming in
and alternating--
I guess you have to
get the parity right.
If you're coming in from this
side and you're alternating,
then you can come around
and visit like that,
and everything is OK.
Back and forth.
Cool.
That was drawn right over here.
That's a zigzag path.
The return path
is just as before.
And so we can use this
edge gadget exactly
as we did before, but now it's
max degree three everywhere.
So that's easy.
In general, using
this trick that here
we had a corner
with a vertex on it.
You can turn that
into a longer path
with various vertices on it.
That will act the same from
a Hamiltonicity perspective.
So that's the key
thing we're doing.
And then it's a matter
of putting things
to fit on the grid.
So that's the first change.
Now, the second change is
going to be a little bit more
drastic, a little weirder.
The vertex gadget used
to be this 3 by 3 thing.
Very hard to get
rid of that, vertex
would have to be
four in the center.
Well, if you did
that, you would be
left with a little
square, an empty square.
And we're going to
need two of those.
So this is the
dumbbell picture used
in many theoretical results.
So we have two of these squares.
We're going to separate
them by a fairly long path
of the right parity.
And the idea is you can have
up to two connections over here
to edges, and up to two
connections over here
for edges.
And typical
connections are going
to look just like we
had before, but it's not
going quite all be like this.
So it used to be we could
have a full edge connection
or we could have a pin
connection as before.
When this edge turns it's going
to use the weirder turn gadget.
So the edges look
basically the same,
it's just the turns that we
changed in the last slide.
OK.
This almost works, but I
have to specify some details.
So for example, easy case.
Degree two vertex.
Suppose the original graph
has a degree two vertex--
we had that in our reduction.
Because in fact, every
other vertex pretty much
was degree two, if you
track all of these things.
When we went from
the directed case
to the bipartite case we
added in lots of vertices,
lots of degree two vertices.
So if we want to simulate
a degree two vertex,
we will just have one of
the edges attaching up here,
and one of the edges
attaching down here.
And again-- in this picture
it's one on the left side,
one on the right side.
And again, we have
this feature that if we
start at any of the PIs we
can get to one of the PJs
by visiting all the EI edges.
So for example, if we start
here we go like this over here.
And we have a choice.
We can either go like this,
end at P3 or go like this
and end at P4.
We visited all the EIs.
But we can't start
at P1 and end at P2.
We want to visit everything.
Start at P1.
If you go out there,
you can never come back.
To come around here,
you've already visited P2.
So we cannot start and
end on the left side.
We cannot start and
end on the right side.
So for a degree two
vertex, that's fine.
We just put one
of the connections
on one side, one on the
other, and we'll come in,
visit everything, come out.
And because we
visit all the EIs,
we can do this kind of
traversal every time.
Now, for a degree
three vertex, this
is a little bit troublesome.
Remember our picture.
What do degree three
vertices look like?
If you follow through
the chain of reductions,
we had this case, and we
had this case, and this one
we converted into that.
And this one we converted
into that I think.
Yup.
Because this was a forced edge.
This was a forced edge and so we
added a dot to represent that.
So the good news is every
time we have a degree three
vertex in the starting graph,
one of the edges is forced.
One of the three
edges is forced.
So it's really a choice
between do you take this one
or do you take this one.
I mean that's, of course,
what we had over here.
So what we're going to do is
take these two edges, which
are exclusively OR'd together.
I choose exactly one of these.
We're going to put that on
one side, so that one of them
will go up here, one of
them will go down here.
And then the forced edge we'll
put over on the other side.
Forced edge is always
chosen, so that
means we'll come in either P1
or P2, or leave on P1 or P2,
depending on which of
those two cases we're in.
And then we will leave
or enter from P3 or P4,
according to which of
the two edges you choose.
Happy?
No?
AUDIENCE: I'm understanding
that we're actually
reducing from a sub-problem
of [INAUDIBLE] bipartite,
max degree three graphs in
that every vertex is connected
to at least one
degree two vertex?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah.
Right.
So we could say at this
point-- in fact, it's planar
bipartite max degree three
graphs where every degree three
vertex is adjacent to
exactly one, or no,
at least one degree two vertex.
And then we can
carry that condition
through all the
reductions, and that would
make this an actual reduction.
Or you can think of this as
a reduction going from here,
just copying all the details.
Yeah.
Other questions?
OK.
I'm a little confused because
there's one more gadget.
But I didn't seem
to use that gadget.
So I'm not sure whether
this is necessary.
But here's another
thing you can do,
which they're using
for the forced edges.
You can have one wire--
sorry, this is the picture.
You can have one edge
gadget that attaches
to both ends of the dumbbell.
So then you have a
choice whether you end up
connecting that edge to
the bottom of the dumbbell
or to the top of the dumbbell.
Sorry.
This is connecting to the
top, and this is connecting
to the bottom, the dumbbell.
So that's another way to do
the same kind of degree three
vertex.
You could have this guy coming
in-- this is the forced edge,
and the forced edge has
to come to this vertex.
You get a choice of whether you
start up here and then leave
along this non-forced
edge, or you first
traverse down this way
and then leave along
this non-forced edge.
So that's another way to do
it, but it seems just as good
as the way I described, which
was to put forced edge only
a one side, and then the other
two guys on the other side.
Unless there's a parity issue.
It could be that this
connection and this connection
have the opposite parities,
which is not good.
Because we want the two
connections-- in this case,
both of these are
going to be white.
And in this case both of
these are going to be black.
So the two non-forced
edges connect
to vertices of the same color.
And I think if you try to
attach one of them over here
and one of them over
here on a variable,
they will have the wrong colors,
they'll have opposite colors.
I think that's why
you need this gadget.
Because now this left connection
and this other left connection
will have the same parity
because this count is odd
I think.
I think that's why you need it.
And that preserves parity.
So it's a bit subtle.
You have to be careful all the
connections preserve parity.
Cool.
So that was max degree
three grid graphs.
Any other questions?
Here is one motivation from this
Papadimitriou/Vazirani paper
for this problem related to
Euclidean traveling salesman
problem.
It's this notion of
degree-bounded minimum spanning
tree.
Minimum spanning tree normally
is a polynomial problem.
We're given some graph, you
want to find a spanning tree.
Tree that this is
all the vertices,
but it can be a tree
instead of just a path.
And it's minimum in that it
has minimum total length of all
the edges.
So that's a polynomial problem.
If I say, well, I want
a minimum spanning tree
where all of the
vertices in the tree
have max degree two,
that is Hamiltonian path,
or I guess really
traveling salesman problem.
So we already proved Euclidean
max degree two minimum spanning
tree is hard.
What about max degree three?
Does that somehow-- does the
branching make it easier,
and the answer is no.
You start from this problem.
And the cool thing
about a max degree
three grid graph is if you look
at any point, at most three
of its neighboring spots
are actual vertices.
One of them has to be absent
in a max degree three.
So what I'm going to do is add a
point really close to that one.
And now you can show in
any minimum spanning tree,
these guys must be connected,
and this one basically
has to be a leaf because
everything else is quite far
away.
I mean at most you have
these guys occupied.
You know that this
is completely absent.
So I add this point.
I'm going to have
to connect this.
it won't be able to connect
any other way if I'm using
the shortest possible length.
And so at that point, if
this has degree three,
there's only two
incident edges left,
and so it's Hamiltonian path
again in the grid graph.
So this is why
they were motivated
to define max degree grid
graphs and prove that hard.
Cool.
Some more geometry.
All right.
So for a long time--
you know, this
is all done in the '80s,
all the grid graph stuff.
We only had square grids.
We couldn't afford
triangles back in the day.
But recently, people started
to think about triangular grids
and hex grids.
Those are the only
tiling regular n-gons.
So you can define the
same kind of thing.
A triangular grid graph,
a hexagonal grid graph.
Again, you take a set of
points in the triangular
lattice or the hex lattice.
Is the hex actually a lattice?
Well, anyway, you know
what I mean, the hex grid.
And you connect
any two points when
they're a unit distance
apart, where that's
defined to be one and one.
So again, we have the notion of
solid, triangular, or hex grid
graph, and there are no holes.
Again, we can characterize the
pixels-- they're not really
pixels-- hexels and trigles?
I don't know.
In the paper they're
all just called pixels.
There's those types of faces.
There's the outside face.
And then there's the hole
faces-- H-O-L-E, not W-H-O-L-E.
OK.
Cool.
They define some other
terms, which I will get to.
Let me tell you what's known
about all of these problems.
So first thing, so these are--
So first thing that's known
is that if you have
a solid grid graph,
then the triangular
case is also polynomial.
So I mentioned solid
square grid graphs are
easy to solve Hamiltonicity in.
Turns out solid
triangular grid graphs
are also easy to solve grid
graphs-- solve Hamiltonicity
in.
Almost all of them are
Hamiltonian in a certain sense,
as long as you check
for some basic things
you shouldn't have.
But hex is open.
So there's actually a ton
of nice open problems still.
Next case is called
a super thin.
So what is super thin?
Super thin means
there are no pixels.
Every face is either a
hole or the outside face.
I don't have an example here,
but this kind of connection
is what you would have
in super thin graphs.
So you've got the whole face
here, a whole face there.
You shouldn't have any of
these pixels to be super thin.
That case turns out to
be polynomial for squares
and hexes, open for triangles.
All right, next
case is called thin.
That one right there implies.
In the thin case, both the
triangle and the square,
problems are NP-hard,
hexes are open.
What does thin mean?
Thin means every vertex
is on the boundary.
So super thin is something like
every edge is on the boundary.
Thin is that every vertex
is on the boundary.
So for example, this
part here is thin.
The banner's actually
drawn in bold here.
If every vertex has bold
edges incident to it,
then we call that thin.
So it's a little bit
thicker than super thin.
So it's also easier to think
of the dual if you care to.
If you draw a vertex for every
pixel, in the super thin case
there are no
vertices in the dual.
In the thin case, the
dual is super thin.
I don't know if that's
easier to think about.
But these cases
are actually hard,
at least in two out
of the three pictures.
One of them we have
already proved.
If you have a max
degree three grid graph,
if max degree is
three then it must
be on the boundary because
of that absent pixel.
So we already showed the thin
case for squares is hard.
Max degree thin implies
thin, four squares.
And so you might ask
what about triangles?
OK, so finally we get
to an actual proof.
It's going to be the
same kind of thing.
I'll skip this detail, but this
is the planar and betting part.
So again, we're going to reduce
from bipartite max degree three
planar Hamiltonicity
as we did before.
And then we're going
to draw it in the plane
in some kind of
parity-preserving sense
with edges routed on
the triangular grid.
That's not hard.
Then we have very
similar looking gadgets.
Although in this case,
a vertex can just
be a little triangle of dots.
The edge gadget's going
to look pretty similar.
It's like a ladder, but now the
ladder has funny rungs on it.
Turns are just what
you would expect.
Notice we get degree five here.
But otherwise,
things are the same.
You can traverse either in
the loopback configuration.
When you have this
pin joint there
you'll be forced to
turn around there.
Or you zigzag all
the way through,
and then that's used
for present edges.
So this is edges you don't
use in Hamiltonian cycle.
These are edges you do use.
And there are two
types of vertices.
There's the ones of one parity
where you always meet-- here,
you're kind of meeting
with three edges,
but you're kind of meeting
on a whole edge, like that.
And from here you
have the choice
whether you do this or do this.
Two of them will be zigzags,
one of them will be double-back.
And then there's the
other parity class
where you only have pin joints.
These are, again, just
connected by single edges,
so they act just
like we had before.
So pretty much the same
reduction, but with different--
in some ways, this is an
easier reduction I think.
Cool.
Now, that was max degree five.
What about max degree four?
So here we had degree
five vertex there.
If we kind of do our same
trick of spreading them around,
you end up with
degree four at most.
And it acts the same.
And the vertices we're going
to explode into a hexagon.
And it works.
So I should say max degree
four triangle is NP-hard.
This reduction
should also be thin.
Previous one may
have also been thin,
but again, all of the
vertices are on the boundary.
So this is the thin
triangle is hard.
Max degree four
We did this one.
So we've done all
the hardest proofs.
That will cease to be
the case in a moment.
OK, here's one more thing.
Max-- so what about hex grids.
I haven't mentioned any
hardness for hex grids yet.
And one thing we know
is max degree three,
writing new squares, but
also hexagons are NP-hard.
Now, this is not so impressive.
Every vertex in the hex grid
has a degree at most three.
But you can't hope
for two, so that's
the best you can hope for in
max degree characterization
with respect to hex grid.
This proof is tricky.
Maybe before I go there let me
just mention one other result.
So this is delayed.
One other notion you can
think about for grid graphs
is called polygonal
grid graphs, and that's
what's supposed to
be illustrated here.
Polygonal's kind of the
opposite of super thin.
So super thin we
had an edge that
had non-pixels on both sides.
In polygonal, every edge
has a pixel on at least one
of the two sides.
So you never have an
edge between two holes
or a hole in the outside face.
That's a polygonal situation.
So that's something
you might assume.
It's sort of like
saying you had a polygon
and then you sort of took
the interior of the polygon,
whereas here, this
was not really
a polygon because it's like
there was a doubled edge there
or something.
That's not really
a nice picture.
So polygonal's
something you might
hope for in the
practical applications,
which we will get to soon.
Funny thing is for polygonal
triangular grid graphs,
the problem is polynomial.
And for polygonal hex grid
graphs, the problem is NP-hard.
And for polygonal square
grid graphs, we don't know.
Another open problem.
I won't prove this.
I think, again, this is
almost always feasible.
It's almost always
a Hamiltonian path.
For this, I'm guessing it
follows from the same proof.
Let's go into this
proof, hex grid hardness.
Again, there's a drawing step.
You're given some
bipartite max degree
three graph, and bipartite
planar max three degree graph.
And then we're going to
draw on the hex grid.
In this case, we're going
to represent variables
by sort of horizontal strips,
just because that's what
is a little bit easier to do.
So it turns out-- I think turns
are really annoying on the hex
grid.
Hard to do a turn.
So we're going to focus
our turn attention
within these little rectangles.
And it turns out you can
draw everything in such a way
that all of the edges are
straight lines, straight line
segments, if you grow the
vertices to be these longer
horizontal things.
So believe that.
Then main idea is a very
similar kind of thing.
In this case, they're
going to draw the pictures
and they're going to draw
all of the forced edges that
must be in there,
and here they haven't
drawn the part in the middle.
There's two ways to fill it in.
Essentially, you could
zigzag back and forth,
just like before.
Or you could go there and
come back, just like before.
So edge gadget looks
pretty reasonable.
These are some more gadgets.
These are like sub-routines
they're going to use.
Their named and they have color
patterns to give you a sense.
This is going to be
the center of a vertex,
and there's a few different
things you could do with that.
This is some kind
of turn gadget.
That's what I called it.
They called it something
a little different.
I think a rosette.
But you can sort of
zigzag, or you can kind of
go there and double-back,
but you end up
with different
orientations at the end.
This is what they call a U turn.
Again, these edges are forced.
You can either use
it as a zigzag,
or they could both kind
of cancel each other out.
Sort of don't meet each other.
So you could do different
kind of connectivity.
With that in mind, here
is all the vertex gadgets.
So I don't know all
the details here.
But I think there's
a lot of cases
because of the different ways
things could be connected.
You could have like one
on top of the-- notice
the dash things are the
rectangles that I had before.
Normally they'd be
really spread out.
So maybe you have two in
the bottom, one on the top,
here I have two on the
top, one on the bottom.
And they could be oriented like
this, or oriented like that.
So there's a lot of
different cases as a result.
The core part in the
middle is the same.
It's pretty much
like the examples
we had before of
essentially like a little 3
by 3 square for the square
case, or a little triangle
in the triangle case.
A little bit bigger in a hex.
It's basically a cycle is
an extra dot in the middle.
But then this was
a U turn gadgets,
so if something
was coming up here,
you could just sort
of turn back around
if you don't want
to use the edge.
I think these are
prob-- well, yeah,
so there's probably
also two parity classes.
There's the turn gadgets.
And it works, but
it's complicated.
I think that's all I'll say
about various grid graphs.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
You said that in
hexagonal grids were open?
Did you mean the vertex?
Every vertex on the boundary--
ERIK DEMAINE: It means every
vertex on the boundary.
AUDIENCE: --[INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: No.
It's not necessarily the same.
So if you have hex grid--
I mean this could still
be a boundary
cycle and you still
have a degree three vertex.
Something like
this part is thin.
And I'm guessing you
could complete that.
So they're probably
very special,
so I could imagine the thin
hex grids are polynomial,
but it's not known.
OK.
One more picture.
This is an actual explicitly
constructed example
from that graph to
this crazy gadgets.
But now you can
see a little better
what the rectangles look like.
If you want to
stretch something out,
there's always horizontal
wires that you can stretch out.
And I keep calling them wires.
So those horizontal
pieces of edge gadgets
that you can stretch out
so that you end up firing
and hitting the next vertex,
which is this rectangle.
And when you spread
out the rectangles
you have to stretch out
these diagonal shots.
Cool.
Those hex grid graphs.
Why do we care about
hex grid graphs so much?
Because Settlers of Catan,
and various other board games
that have a hex grid.
Now, has anyone here not
played Settlers of Catan?
OK, a few.
There's a whole game to it.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
What I'm going to
focus on is this card.
It's called longest road.
So in general, you're
constructing cities.
Don't worry about cities.
But you're constructing
these road segments.
They're edges on the hex grid.
And the longest road says that
you get two points, two victory
points, if you have the longest
road, meaning the longest
path that can be
formed using edges
of your color versus edges
of anyone else's color,
then you get two points.
So here is the idea.
Settlers of Catan has
randomness and stuff like that,
but again, if we look
at a mate-in-1 problem,
that goes out the window.
Just can I win in this one move.
There's no randomness to that.
Let's suppose you have
tons of resources.
This is what you
need to build a road.
And inconveniently,
your opponents
have built cities and things
in all of these white spots,
so you're not allowed
to build roads there.
That's just part of the rules.
So that's the opponent's
form obstacles.
And then because you
have infinite cash,
you can basically build
the entire grid graph here.
And then to figure out whether
there's a really long road,
namely a road length n, where
n is the number of pixels that
were not occupied by opponents.
Number of dots that are
not occupied by opponents
is NP-complete.
Cool?
And your opponent has a
slightly shorter road,
so you really have to
distinguish whether you
had the longest road.
In fact, I like to say
mate-in-0 is NP-complete,
deciding whether you've already
won the game is NP-complete.
Now you don't even need cash.
It's just I give
you a configuration.
Do you have the longest
road is NP-hard.
So it's the only mate-in-0
hardness result I know of.
Maybe we can find more.
OK, so that's why
hex grids are cool.
Let's do some more games.
Here is another Nikoli
puzzle, Slither Link.
Their more famous one.
So you're given a
grid of squares.
Each square is either blank,
meaning no constraint,
or there's a number saying
there should be exactly two
edges among those four.
And there should be exactly
three edges among those four.
Your goal is to find a
cycle-- not Hamiltonian
but just a cycle, doesn't visit
all the dots-- that satisfies
that neighboring constraint.
So here there were exactly two.
Here there are exactly
three edges in your cycle.
OK?
This is the very first
puzzle on the website.
Again, there are books
on Slither Link puzzles.
And here is a little
overkill of a hardness proof,
but in one slide.
So this is a reduction from
Hamiltonicity in planar graphs.
So you take any planar graph
and draw it in the grid.
This is one of the very
first steps we did today.
And then if you do that, there
are two types of vertices.
There's the ones
you have to visit
and there's the ones
you don't have to visit.
Now, we know grid
graphs are hard.
So we could actually
assume all of the vertices
have to be visited.
But for whatever reason,
this proof did not do that.
This is back in 2000,
so at that point maybe
it was not so well known.
But these days, grid
graphs, Hamiltonicity
is used a lot, but
probably not so much then.
So anyway, there's
this gadget which
is you can do whatever
you want, basically.
These are the vertices that
don't need to be visited.
The key gadget is this one.
So let's focus our
attention here.
We have these ones which means
the cycle must come here.
And so collectively these are
going to form Hamiltonian cycle
constraints.
You're building a cycle and
you have to visit these ones.
Now it turns out no matter
which end you come in
and which end you leave, you
can visit all of the ones.
You could be adjacent
to all of the ones.
So different turns
are going straight.
And so if there is
a Hamiltonian cycle,
you'll be able to
visit all the ones.
And conversely, if you
can visit all the ones,
that must be a
Hamiltonian cycle.
The one extra thing
we need to say,
if you just glue these
gadgets together,
then there's no-- you can go
from anywhere to anywhere.
So you just add in
some zeroes here
if you don't want there to be a
connection from left to right.
So you can use that to
delineate the boundary.
So this could actually do
a sub-graph of a grid graph
even more special, or you leave
a clear if there's an edge.
And so you get a
picture like this.
In this case, they're
using these bunch of zeroes
to say, well, you
don't have to visit
these pixels because they're
just simulating a big edge.
But we really have
infrastructure
to simulate edges.
We don't really need that.
So that's a really easy proof.
I would say in
general, what you have
to be careful about here
is that edges are free,
because in Hamiltonian
cycle you're not
supposed to pay for the edges.
You just have to
visit every vertex.
But that's really easy
in this kind of set up.
Another Nikoli puzzle,
Hashiwokakero, bridge building.
You have a bunch of
dots in the plane.
Each dot has a number on it,
specifying a degree request.
And your goal is to make
a connected structure.
It looks like it's
usually a tree,
but that's not part
of the constraints.
Where every vertex
has that degree,
you can use multiple edges.
You could build multiple bridges
between the same two cities.
And so there's four incident to
that, eight incident to that,
and everything's orthogonal.
It can only build
horizontal, vertical.
You can't build a
bridge like this.
You're not allowed
to make turns.
AUDIENCE: Same as
standard coding
where you've only got two
parallel edges per [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Ah.
OK.
So also standard is that max
double-edge, no triple-edge.
Thank you.
Obviously, i haven't
actually played.
It won't matter
in this reduction.
So here we are reducing from
Hamiltonicity in grid graphs.
So these are edges that
we might want to allow.
In general, we're going to use
these little ones to delineate
the boundary.
It's just the same kind
of trick we use here
with Euclidean degree three MST.
We added a little dot
just off to the side.
It's not a metric problem
here, so we're just
adding it one unit over.
That delineates the boundary.
It basically is forced to
connect into the only neighbor.
If you tried to do this
kind of connection,
you'd end up being disconnected.
You'd just get a
single edge there.
Because ones will
only face ones.
Sorry.
The other constraint
is you're not allowed
to have crossing bridges.
That won't matter here.
So we delineate the
boundary at the ones,
and then every other
vertex is going
to have value two plus the
number of boundary edges
incident to it.
So here it happens to be four,
here it happens to be three.
So I could have gone like this.
That would have been fine.
But in the cycle, I happened
to go around that way.
That's representing the cycle.
So again, very easy.
This shows you how useful it
is once you have grid graphs.
You can do any problem on any
grid, pretty much, that has
any kind of tour-like thing.
That will be hard
using these reductions.
So that's why we care.
All right.
Here's some
practical motivation.
Well, I have a game here.
But suppose you're
mowing your lawn.
And so usually a lawnmower
has a circular cutting tool,
but in this game it happens
to be a square cutting tool.
It's basically the same.
And you have some polygon with
holes that you want to mow.
There's actually two
versions of the problem.
And they were introduced by
Arkin, Fekete and Mitchell,
2000.
One's called Lawn Mowing.
So Lawn Mowing you're
given a polygon.
You have to visit, let's say,
if we're using a square cutter,
you have to visit every
pixel of the polygon.
You have to visit
the entire-- you're
moving a unit square around.
You've got to visit everything
to cut the entire lawn.
But you're also allowed
to leave the polygon,
because for a lawn mower you
can go outside the grass.
You can go onto the pavement.
Most lawnmowers that
doesn't break it.
So that's called Lawn Mowing.
You can go outside if you want.
And the other problem
is called Milling.
And with Milling,
you can't go outside.
That video game is probably
some hybrid between these two
problems, but both
problems have been
considered a lot, especially
from an approximation
standpoint.
But there are lots of situations
where this kind of problem
comes up.
Suppose you're laser cutting.
This is one of the
first laser cutter
projects we did with
George Hart, back in 2003,
where cutting out these
two-headed salamanders
like that and then
assembling them.
If you've ever been to G6 in
Stata, it's hanging there.
So you can think of this
laser cutting problems,
you have a lot of dots and
you have to cut them all.
That is literally what
happens to laser cutter
is pulsing with little dots.
And in this case it
looks pretty clear
how to connect them together.
But if you're cutting many
salamanders out of one sheet,
and you think of the
salamander's pretty small,
that's like a TSP problem
or really a milling problem.
You have to visit all
these things using
the shortest-- it's really
a lawn mowing problem.
So you can turn off
the laser and you
can move around somewhere else
that you don't want to visit.
3D printing is like lawn
mowing problem in each layer.
So 3D printing is done
by printing each layer
and then stacking
them up one at a time.
So in each layer you have
to deposit material in FDM,
say we're additive printing.
You have to deposit material.
If you're doing laser
curing, same kind of thing.
How do you move the laser with
the shortest amount of work.
It's called milling.
I don't have an image for this.
Because if you're doing NC
milling you have a drill
and you're moving the drill
around to cut out some shape
or to cut a region.
There you're not allowed
to go outside the shape you
want to cut, because you go
outside, you cut too much.
And you don't want to
have to pay to retract.
There are other versions of the
problem where you can retract
the cutting bit and so on.
So of course we proved
milling is hard.
That is exactly the
Hamilton [INAUDIBLE]
graphs if you're not
allowed to leave the region.
Of course, that also shows
that lawn mowing is hard
because you never want
to go outside the region.
One fun result is lawn
mowing is hard even when you
have no holes in your region.
So if you cut these little
slits, from a lawn mowing
perspective it basically
makes no difference
because you could
still go over it,
and it doesn't really
save you anything
to not have to cut that.
So lawn mowing is hard
even without holes.
Cool.
I have one more problem.
Do you want to see it?
OK.
So here's-- sorry--
a brief warm-up.
Suppose you have a grid graph.
You rotate it 45 degrees.
You can represent each of these
vertices as a vertical segment
if they're black parity
or horizontal segment.
If they're white parity
such that segments
intersect, if and only if
there's an edge joining.
So these are unit
orthogonal segments.
This is called an
intersection graph
where the vertices
are the objects,
and the edges are
whether things intersect.
I need that, so Hamiltonicity
in these graphs is hard.
Here's a problem called
minimum turn milling.
So a big issue for 3D
printing, for milling,
usually when you're cutting
or you're depositing material,
you can move really
fast in a straight line.
But when you need
to make a turn you
have to basically come to a
stop and then speed up again.
So suppose you have infinite
acceleration, so to speak,
or close to infinite
acceleration.
So once you're going straight
you can go arbitrarily
far for the same cost,
and what you really
pay for is the slowing
down and speeding back up
at every corner.
So then you want to minimize
the number of turns, not
the lengths.
This is one of my
first hardness proofs
that was not about puzzles.
I think the original
paper was 2000,
the journal version's 2005.
So suppose you have one of these
rectangle intersection graphs.
What we're going to do is
replace each of these things
with a cycle, and then
thicken that cycle.
This is a thin grid
graph, not super thin.
Maybe super thin.
Here it's super
thin, and here you
have a little square
that you're cutting with.
So each of these things you
have to make four turns.
Then also, to go from one
of these to one of these,
to go from one vertex to
the next, you need a turn.
So in general, you're going
to need 5n turns in order
to visit n of these
original segments.
And you can do that
if and only if there's
a Hamiltonian cycle
in the original graph,
which was this picture.
Basically, if you
come in one position--
so here's one of these
rectangles you want to visit.
You come in one
place and you know
that you want to leave
on some other place.
So you double this edge--
you're going to cut it twice.
That's allowed in this model.
And then you loop around.
And the number of turns here
is exactly one to come in,
four to go around, and
then one to come out.
In general, it's one
per edge in the cycle,
and four per vertex
in the cycle.
So again, Hamiltonicity
gives us what we want.
Even where we minimize
the number of turns,
we can simulate that by counting
vertices as turns, basically.
And that's it for Hamiltonicity.